Medicaid is no longer a public charge issue.
USCIS change the rules in 2022.
If you receive Medicaid,
or if you're sponsoring somebody
and you and the sponsor receives Medicaid,
it does not prevent a green card issuance
unless that Medicaid is for some long term
healthcare issue.
But if it's for immunizations,
emergency situations,
visiting a clinic,
none of that is a public charge anymore.
You can also apply on the exchange for Obamacare
under the Affordable Healthcare Act
for insurance as well.
That also is no longer considered
government assistance.
So basically
almost any medical insurance you're gonna get,
you're gonna be okay.